لحظة من الراحة المطلقة لهذين الزوجين الأفغان
المنفصلين عن أطفالهما أثناء
الإخلاء من مطار كابول قبل 10 أيام تم
لم شملهم أخيرًا في حالة الطوارئ
بأبو ظبي ،
وأخبرت أطفالي بالجلوس في مكان ما
ذهبت إليه للحصول على مساعدة طبية وقلت أنني سأكون
مرة أخرى ولكن عندما فعلت ذلك ، لم تكن عائلتي الصغيرة
موجودة عندما سألت من حولهم ،
أخبروني أنهم وضعوهم على متن طائرة
بالفعل ، لقد ركبت الطائرة بنفسي لكنهم
لم يكونوا هناك في
نور وتم نقل زوجته في الأصل
جواً إلى الدوحة في قطر بينما  وصل
طفلان إلى مدينة أبوظبي
الإنسانية كملاذ مؤقت
للعديد من الأفغان الذين فروا من بلادهم
جيدًا ، وقد استضافت الإمارات ما يقرب من 9000 أفغاني
، وقد تم إيواء العديد منهم
هنا في
مدينة الإمارات الإنسانية ومجموعاتها مثل  هذه التي
تتم معالجتها على أساس يومي على أمل
أن ينتقلوا من هنا
بسرعة كبيرة
إلى الولايات المتحدة
من بينهم آلاف النساء
والأطفال بما في ذلك الطفلة سارة التي ولدت لها  e
في أبو ظبي بعد أيام فقط من
وصول عائلتها المنهكة ،
يقول والدها عبد الصبحه إنه
ممتن لكل الدعم ، نعم نعم
أنا أقدر
الناس لأن
كل شيء جيد لنا مرافق
أفضل لنا من أفغانستان ،
كل شيء جيد
الأمير محمد بن
تعهد زايد بتوفير الرعاية والدعم الاجتماعي للأسر المعرضة للخطر وخاصة
النساء والأطفال
أثناء تواجدهم على أراضي الإمارات العربية المتحدة ، على
الرغم من أنهم يائسون
لمواصلة رحلتهم
حتى قبل أسبوعين ، كان فارد
مترجمًا لقوات التحالف بقيادة الولايات المتحدة
في  أفغانستان
بالنسبة لي من الصعب جدًا
العودة إلى أفغانستان
لأنني أعمل
أكثر من 13 عامًا حيث يستخدمون
الحكومة ،
ولا أريد العودة إلى هناك
ما لم يكن لدينا أمنًا مثاليًا
ونشعر بالأمان لأنفسنا لذلك هناك
رحلات جوية كل يوم  إلى الولايات المتحدة ،
فأنت تأمل فقط أن تحصل على إحدى
تلك الرحلات قريبًا جدًا ، ونأمل أن
نتمنى
أن لا 2 ننتقل سريعًا
في شا  الأمن والسلامة في المدينة الإنسانية ،
إنه لا يتحدث عن ما حدث في
ذلك اليوم في مطار كابول. سعيد فقط
لأنه عاد مع أطفاله
مرتاحين لترك أهوال
أفغانستان وراءه
بيكي أندرسون سي إن إن أبو ظبي